now A Mother 3 received a 28-month
sentence for taking abortion pills at
home after the legal limit
44 year old Carla Foster received the
medication via the pills by post scheme
introduced in lockdown but wasn't honest
about how far along her pregnancy was at
the time of her consultation
now Sally can I bring you in here what
do you think of this case and
her sentencing I don't think there's any
woman who
chooses to have an abortion lightly and
I certainly see it in my
email box every single week the
the tortured decision-making that women
do go through when they decide to have
an abortion and in some cases not
this
this mum mum of three
will will have made an absolutely
horrific decision and I I don't think
prison is the place for her she she has
flashbacks she is traumatized she has
depression
she is haunted by the face of her dead
daughters
um face every single day I think she
knows she made a mistake a custodial
sentence is not the answer
and palm this you know is going back to
a law that was created in 1861
do you think it's right that we're still
using it today I think the whole
situation is really complex and it is
particularly horrendous and what we've
got to remember is why do people get
tentacle to Prison number one it's to so
they're not a danger to the public
number two is to re rehabilitate them
now is this woman going to go to prison
is she a danger to the public or is she
going to be rehabilitated in prison I
don't think she's going to fit either of
those categories how far along was she
between 32 and 34 weeks
because that's like seven months eight
months that's eight months
yeah that's so disgusting that's
literally disgusting
um yeah I mean there's babies that have
survived at six months like six and a
half so I actually think that's gross
and yeah she should go to jail for that
but what do you think about it that's
crazy but what do you think this
represents for women's rights this
decision that she's gone to prison for
this what do you think that's done for
women's rights and the autonomy to our
own bodies
I think
I mean you have the right to do what you
want with your body but not to someone
else's body
and that's a full grown child especially
at eight months
can you imagine if someone if that baby
was born early and they threw an
eight-month-old baby off of a off of a
bridge something like that everyone
there would be an uproar there would be
an absolute uproar but for some reason
she has no consequences for taking an
abortion pill at eight months I don't I
don't think there should be no
consequences in our country abortion is
legal to the upper limit of 24 weeks I
think you know whether or not that
should be lowered or hired is a matter
for the Democratic process
I don't agree with what she did however
I cannot understand what is going to be
gained by sending her to prison she has
three sons one of whom who has special
needs how are those children going to
benefit from their mother being in
prison for over a year because again if
you if you let her do that then other
women will see that and do the same
thing I think we have laws for a reason
so I don't think it's like oh I can just
break the law and have no consequence
you broke the law like I don't think
anybody's saying it's right well we're
not saying it's right or wrong or I
should say that's my view on it what
we're saying is the punishment does the
punishment fit what she's done but
that's the more the question but the
punishment the the reason that people
are sent to prison is for rehabilitation
or because if they're a danger to the
public now this woman isn't going to go
and attack other women and cause
abortions is she and in addition to that
if I may I've held the hand of many many
rape victims many victims of incest who
make that difficult decision it's never
somebody else's decision it's that
individual's decision for whatever
reason so taking away the right to
abortions or the right to do that to
your body it's a big it's a really
complex area and it's something that
you've got to tread really lightly well
eight months you don't try think that
should be legal for them we're not
saying it's not about the legality
because I'm just asking you personally
you don't think up to eight months it
should be legal what I'm saying is that
when they abort abort a baby at seven or
eight weeks it's flushed down the toilet
now she's a mother she knew that a baby
that was already eight months she's not
going to flush that down the toilet she
wasn't thinking straight her head is a
mess now if she's mentally or
emotionally unstable what good is it to
send her to prison I think it it shows
women you can't do that because if you
if you if you don't have her go to
prison then other women are going to do
the same you're never going to get yours
you're never going to end up eight
months pregnant considering taking
illegal pills in terms of you should
have taken before 10 10 weeks
unless you are in an absolutely
horrendous situation unless you have
been raped unless you are in a domestic
violence situation 99.5 99.5 like I'm
just correcting you because I this isn't
correct 99.5 of abortions are elective
I've looked up the stats here it's not
true the majority are literally elective
it's like
0.05 that are um because of what you're
mentioning what do you mean by elective
elective as in they don't have a reason
I'm going to disagree with that figure
because I never seen that itself
you know I know that having dealt with
vaping
technically that would be considered an
elective
um abortion no that there's a box they
can click it but if you've been raped
you elect to have an abortion or if
you've been a victim of incest it's
considered an elective you you choose to
have no it's no it's not it says right
upon it it's right so if you're just
discussing on a personal level ticking a
box doesn't really necessarily mean
anything about someone's experience why
they're there I think the bigger picture
which we believe women that's what they
said they said why they got the abortion
Don't We Believe women here but I don't
think anyone's questioning that this is
this is such an unusual case and in fact
it's 0.1 percent of abortions happen
after 20 24 weeks on that basis alone
this is so unusual the vast majority in
this country happened before 10 weeks
and in any case
no no woman just goes oh I'm not going
to take my contraception pill I'm
actually I'm just going to go for an
abortion because it's just easier right
but this is all based on stories and
what they're saying oh you have to
believe people because if somebody comes
to me and says I've been raped I have to
give I have to believe them I can't say
I don't believe you why would I just
openly believe women I think it's very
dangerous territory to start saying that
we shouldn't Women Believe women who
have either been raped or have been
victims of interested men when they've
gone through something if they're
victims or something
no you should believe people yeah
absolutely no I think you need evidence
at the end of the day because I think
we're in a dangerous territory when we
just openly believe you can completely
defame someone's reputation off of what
a story no you need evidence if that was
your son you wouldn't want them to do
that well this lady wasn't accusing
anyone she was asking for help and I
don't think you asked for help unless
you you are in trouble unless you have a
serious problem on your hands